neo's estranged wife crystal fouls for
divorce
just after making some stunning
allegations against the singer happy
life happy wife is the truest statement
ever well guess who doesn't seem so
happy this week
et's obtained the just filed court docs
crystal lists the couple's separation
date as july 22nd
less than a month after the singer told
us this so once i realized what i wanted
and who i needed to be for her
we're in a great place the model says
their marriage is quote broken with no
hope for reconciliation
and she re-ups her claim that neo
recently fathered a child with another
woman
yeah let's recap how all this started
yeah i'm gonna keep it together i'm keep
it together over the weekend crystal
instagramed an emotional message
claiming neo cheated on her with
multiple women
and she didn't mince words while
reflecting on the end of their marriage
um
quote eight years of lies and deception
to say i'm heartbroken and disgusted is
an understatement crystal also hinted
neo wanted them to work through this
writing quote to ask me to stay and
accept it is absolutely insane
soon after nia responded on twitter
quote for the sake of our children my
family and i will work through our
challenges behind closed doors personal
matters are not to be addressed and
dissected in public forums neo and
crystal share three kids together i got
itty bitty's at the house perfect court
fouling she's requesting alimony child
support
and physical custody of the children the
two tied the knot in 2016 and oddly
enough neo actually filed for divorce in
2020 but he and crystal reconciled and
celebrated the birth of their third
child last year
so don't lie to yourself be honest with
yourself as neo explains to e.t in june
one of his latest tracks was inspired by
their rekindled romance
[Music]
what was her reaction when she first
heard it uh when she first heard the
song
um it reminded her of the time that we
were in when i wrote the song and you
know that that was that was kind of that
was a terry moment you know but i mean
because it was written uh the song was
written kind of in the throes of us
going through potentially getting
divorced i'm the reason that you felt so
out of place
i've kind of made a career out of taking
i guess negative situations and turning
it into song form and making that you
know kind of the soundtrack for people
to to live their lives to or you know to
break up to to get back together to
whatever the case may be and uh it feels
good it feels good to know that that for
one it feels good to know that you don't
go through these things by yourself you
know what i'm saying uh uh just again
the black and white black white and gray
of what love is everybody kind of goes
through similar things and and you know
to have a song that kind of relates and
resonates with what's going on with you
it it softens the blow a little bit
[Music]